at una 4th 1989 didn't happen as far as
the government's concerned and as if on
cue and I assure you this is no setup
just seconds before you came to us the
police arrived
I should explain we're on a public
street we're exactly 2 miles away from
Tiananmen Square and yet the police are
here they wouldn't be on any normal day
we've every right to be here on this
street to report and on any other day
they wouldn't stop us but today that
police car they're radioed about ten
minutes ago this police van has now
turned up and they're not stopping us
that I assume that as soon as we finish
this report they will ask us to move on
it's quite extraordinary really Steven
that this is a country which is what the
world's second largest economy now it's
a global player in almost every sense
and yet still they manage and insist on
suppressing and effectively airbrushing
the event which was absolutely pivotal
to China's modern history and answer to
your question it will not be marked
anywhere in public in China this spot
right here marks the spot where one of
those people to be killed in June 1989 a
man known only as mr. Jang he died at
this spot it's two miles from Tiananmen
Square Square that gives you a sense
that these protests and the deaths which
followed did not take place just in the
square people were running out of the
square running into all the side streets
the army on the orders of the Communist
Party which remains in power simply
opened fire on them I've seen some
really gruesome pictures as I've been
researching the story of people who were
simply trampled by the tanks the tanks
drove over people it's an event that's
not covered China would like to say it
has moved on it's fair to say look
around look at the modernity around us
it has moved on in every way except one
the PERT the Communist Party remains in
power and it was their crackdown in 1989
that allowed them to remain in power to
this day with no one questioning them